we've learned that axial precession it
doesn't change it's not a change in the
tilt or the obliquity of our rotational
axis it's a change in the direction and
over a long period of time 26,000 years
it kind of traces out a circle and the
main effect of that is that if we wait
long enough that our rotational axis or
you could say almost the North Pole will
be pointed in a different direction and
so if then if our rotational axis is
pointed in a different direction
after a long enough time then the time
then the absolute point in our orbit if
we use the Sun as our frame of reference
the point in our orbit when we are most
pointed away from the Sun or when the
northern hemisphere is most pointed away
from the Sun will be earlier in the
orbit now it was very I emphasize that
that won't necessarily mean earlier in
our calendar because our calendar by
definition takes into consideration I
guess or it's more based on when we are
farthest away from farthest tilted away
from the Sun or furthest tilted towards
the Sun so on when even though if we
wait 1800 years like the example I gave
we will be most tilted away from the Sun
we will have our or the northern
hemisphere will have its winter will
have its winter equinox at an earlier
point in the orbit according to our
calendar it will still be December 22nd
if our calendar instead where's base and
it's not based on this but if our
calendar was based on the exact point in
orbit if our calendar was based on the
exact point in orbit then our year would
be about 20-25 minutes longer every year
and then the dates actually would then
the the the date for the start of winter
actually would go back it would you know
1800 years later the date of the start
of winter would be November 22nd but
that's not how we measure our calendar
our calendar is actually measured from
equinox to equinox from the December
22nd or 21st there's slight fluctuations
depending on the calendar but that will
always be the date that we are most
pointed away from the Sun that will not
be necessarily the date that we are at
at this exact position at this exact
position relative to the Sun itself and
that's why the actual Peary
perihelion does change because if this
is always December 22nd and if we at
first assumed that the perihelion is
always at the same fixed point in space
relative to the Sun although that's not
exactly the case but if we make that
assumption then it will be further and
further after that December 22nd further
and further after that time that we are
most pointed away from the Sun and
that's why you have this that's why you
have this kind of pushing back of the
perihelion now what I want to add to
this video is that the perihelion itself
is also changing so if I draw if I draw
the Sun again and right now our orbit
may be right now our orbit looks
something like this and I'm going to
exaggerate the eccentricity of it I am
going to exaggerate the eccentricity of
it just so that the perihelion and the
aphelion are a little bit clearer so
right now this is the perihelion this is
the aphelion based on the way I've drew
it right over there I'm doing in
different colors I don't want to show
that that's necessarily where Earth is
for helium and aphelion there is also a
rotation of this of the of the
perihelion and sometimes this is called
the precession of the precession of the
perihelion or perihelion precession or
AB Siddal prep Siddal precession these
are all very hard to say and so if we
wait several thousands of years our
orbit might look a little bit like this
our orbit will look like this the actual
perihelion will have rotated so our
orbit will look like this the actual the
actual ellipse would have rotated a
little bit you wait a little bit longer
it will go it will look like it might
look like this and obviously I'm once
again talking about over thousands and
thousands of years from a year-to-year
basis you really wouldn't notice the
difference but what that does is is we
talked about the axial precession that
this change in direction of our
rotational axis it takes 26,000 years to
complete one period 26 26,000 years so
26,000 years from today are our polar
axis if we don't if we don't if we don't
think about our rotational axis if we
don't if we aren't too concerned about
the actual change in tilt which there
will be some small change in tilt but
26,000 years from now our
all will roughly point in the same
direction again we would have completed
one whole period of axial precession
however it does not take 26,000 years
for whatever our date of perihelion is
today so it's in it's in January I
actually don't know the exact date you
could look that up but whatever that
date is in January it will not take
26,000 years for it to be that date
again and it would have taken 26,000
years if the perihelion itself were not
changing if it always stayed fixed over
here if it was if it if we did not have
this app Siddal precession but since it
is also changing you can kind of say it
is over thousands of years moving in
that direction while our while our jet
our date our January date is moving in
that direction they will actually meet
sooner so that the precession will be
back on whatever day it is on January
less than 26,000 years from now and
actually the exact time and I haven't
done the calculation but this is what
I've read is that it will be 21,000
21,000 years from now and then on top of
that if that's not enough for you that
the actual not only is the direction of
Earth's rotational axis changing and the
tilt is changing and that the perihelion
and the aphelion are also rotating
around it's also the case that the
eccentricity of the orbit itself is
changing so over long periods of time
Earth's orbit becomes more or less
eccentric and we've learned that almost
circular has well if you're circular you
have no eccentricity and then you can
become more and more eccentric which
means you're more and more of kind of
this flattened out ellipse and so and
these cycles occur so these eccentricity
cycles occur on over approximately 100
100 thousand years and so to revisit the
Milankovitch cycles and once again this
is a theory we're not sure whether this
is necessarily causing our ice ages or
whether this is necessarily a major
influence over long-term climate change
but the Milankovitch cycle or the theory
of Milankovitch cycles is that over long
periods of time if the eccentricity
changes enough and if it coincides with
when the perihelion and the seasons also
coincide maybe that's enough to start an
ice age or maybe that's enough to take
us out of an ice age and actually if you
want to throw
even more on that the actual plane of
our orbit also changes over time mainly
because of interactions with the outer
planets anyway I'll leave you there you
can mention this is a very complex topic
but hopefully you now have an
appreciation of all the different ways
our orbit can change and maybe start to
think about how that might affect our
weather although we don't we don't
necessarily know how it does it or
whether you even really does affect
going into or out of ice ages